[Music]
the dark side of the force is a pathway
to many abilities some consider to be
unnatural is it possible to learn this
power not from a Jedi
welcome back everyone it's Charlie Happy
New Year is I'm posting this video this
is gonna be my Mandalorians season to
top 10 predictions video if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos I will be doing
mandalorian videos during the break
they've already announced when season 2
episodes are gonna start so we're not
gonna have to wait too long before we
get season 2 they're also finally
selling baby Yoda merch so we'll do a
giveaway for that all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your predictions about season 2 on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this big spoiler warning for
everything that happened on the
Mandalorians season 1 as we go through
our top 10 here so starting with number
10 they won't find more members of
Yoda's race I think this is a pretty
easy prediction to make the whole idea
of the armourers mission that she tasked
him with is that he's supposed to go
find his people and if you know anything
about the way George Lucas treated the
Yoda character so protectively actively
seeking to prevent other people inside
Star Wars and Lucasfilm the TV shows the
books the movies the video games from
creating any new backstory for the Yoda
character anytime anyone got even close
to saying what planet Yoda came from or
who his parents were what his childhood
was like in the Jedi Order he would drop
the banhammer hard no explaining Yoda
yes George Lucas did sell Lucasfilm and
the rights to Star Wars to Disney so
technically he doesn't control it
anymore since 2012 but all the current
people making Star Wars like you know
Dave Filoni Jon Favreau worship at the
feet of George Lucas so at least they
aren't gonna trample on his wishes and
just completely explain every last
detail about Yoda in a way that George
Lucas never wanted to see on screen
there was a joke that George Lucas did
tell though about Yoda during the
commentaries for the blu-ray editions a
couple years ago he called Yoda the
illegitimate child of Kermit and Miss
Piggy but obviously that's him just
joking number 9 even though they might
not find all of Yoda's race they will
probably get information on the planet
that baby Yoda himself came from which
might not necessarily be the original
homeworld of Yoda's race just a planet
that baby Yoda is believed to have been
born on he's about 50 years old that
means he was born around the same time
the Anakin Skywalker was born before the
events of Phantom Menace theory craft
all you want about the possible
connection between two powerful force
beings
like that being born in such close
proximity to each other but we really
don't know enough about Yoda's race to
know what it's like when they give birth
their amphibious looking creatures they
could give birth like most warm-blooded
mammals but they could also be hatched
from eggs like frogs lay eggs but even
then that's just trading on a lot of
offhanded remarks that George Lucas
makes calling Yoda a frog like creature
finding the planet that he came from
though is the first major step in
finding the ancestral home of Yoda's
race but I think finding their ancestral
home planet is something that's probably
gonna take the entire run of the series
if they ever find it it'd be like
treasure hunters finally the lost city
of gold in the second season of a TV
show that's not something you do right
away number 8 baby Yoda still won't
speak with words like Yoda spoke with
right now he just garbles and coos like
a human baby it's not clear if he's even
capable of speaking words and just
chooses not to because he is 50 years
old
even if he's a baby he's had much more
time to learn how to communicate through
body language than a human baby would at
the same level of biological development
another really easy prediction to make
is that he's probably not gonna grow a
lot physically larger I think part of
the idea and doing a character like
someone from Yoda's race who ages and
physically matures so slowly is that if
the mandalorian series runs furred like
five seasons baby oda will physically
stay a little baby for the entire run of
the series but number seven follow-up he
will learn and develop mentally and as a
force user a lot so it's not like he's
completely frozen developmentally his
ability to use the force in different
ways will get more fine-tuned and when
he does choose to Hulk out in moments of
great distress like when he lashes out
an anger to protect the mandalorian like
force choking cardoon those types of
abilities he manifests will get bigger
and bigger crazier and crazier and just
cooler to watch on screen right now
though as far as we can tell from the
season 1 episodes every time he's done
that he's done it instinctively the
forced choking thing was a little bit
different because of the way he was
twirling his tiny little hands and
fingers around making tiny little fists
you don't really see human babies get
that elaborate and dramatic with their
poses if you were at the same level
developmentally as a human baby he would
just start kicking and screaming and
flailing his arms all over the place the
motions that baby Yoda was making
during this or the same that you might
see an older version of Yoda during the
original trilogy making implying that
he's a lot smarter than he seems
number six another easy prediction to
make the armorer said that some of the
Mandalorians former clan members in the
covert here may have escaped before the
Imperials came back and killed these
mandos that's probably a teaser that
we'll see a few then pop up around the
galaxy in future seasons when they go to
other planets in the outer rim and just
to be clear even though these ones were
killed off there are still little
pockets of Mandalorians like this all
over the outer rim planets hiding out
after the great purge so I think it's
implied that there's still at least a
couple hundred or even a couple thousand
still left alive after the great purge
just scattered all over the galaxy just
waiting for someone to rally them to
rise up again if only there was a
Mandalorian character out there using
something that the older Mandalorians
used as a totem to rally around whom you
know what could you actually use is a
signal to rally all the Mandalorians
together
number five obviously I'm talking about
the dark saber if you never watched the
animated Clone Wars series or Star Wars
rebels the dark saber was used by the
Mandalorians in ancient times as a
symbol to rally around in unite all
their warring clans together under a
single banner right now I'm off Gideon
has it it's implied that he stole it
sometime during the Great Purge on
Mandalore during the course of the
original trilogy of course I think
they'll let Pedro pascal's Mandalorian
character play with it at some point on
screen but I don't expect him to steal
it back from off Gideon permanently
during season two seriously if we're
talking about video game mechanics here
like it's a bit of a fetch quest series
where he goes around collecting bounties
so that he can pay for upgrades to his
armor the dark saber is like the
legendary drop that you get after one of
the big final bosses in your final raid
encounters if the show runs four or five
seasons they would probably save
something like the Mandalorian wielding
the dark saber on a regular basis for
one of the final seasons but the mando
got his jetpack upgrade at the end of
season one dark saber upgrade obviously
off in the distance there's got to be
some other upgrades that he will acquire
during season two so number four next
big armor upgrade he's probably gonna
get and it's actually a pretty easy
upgrade is just to get more larger
rockets that he can fire out of his
jetpack larger than the whistling burrs
that he carries in his gauntlet
because a lot of the weapons that he has
are inspired by Boba Fett's weapons in
the original trilogy and they're still a
couple weapons they haven't done from
the animated Clone Wars series and Star
Wars rebels that those Mandalorians used
and because of Star Wars obviously Star
Wars trades a lot on the trope of super
weapons the arc pulse generator was a
Mandalorian designed weapon but it was
used against Mandalorians during the
animated series they could introduce
some stuff like that eventually to right
now the only super weapon that we know
about on the show that the villain
obviously Moff Gideon wants to acquire
is baby Yoda he is literally the super
weapon that he wants to use to take over
the galaxy again so number three will
probably also learn the exact nature of
Mothe Gideon and dr. Pershing cloning
plans for baby Yoda and how they intend
on using his power and his DNA to create
an army of force-sensitive clones
it was also implied that Moff Gideon
plans to use baby Yoda himself like a
weapon exploiting him as he grows up
possibly turning him to the dark side of
the force in the process because if you
abused someone like that over a long
course of time they would also fall to
the dark side to probably wind up
killing you and everyone around them but
then going on a tear and turning into
someone just as bad as Emperor Palpatine
best example that was that funny scene
at the beginning of episode 8 with the
scout troopers they both punched baby
Yoda which is almost an unforgivable act
but baby Oda literally bit one of them
on the finger so if you mistreat him he
will literally and metaphorically come
back to bite you I'm really hoping
though that we get to see inside the
actual imperial facilities that Moff
Gideon is using in that he controls like
inside their Imperial version of the
cloning facility because of all the
implied cloning stuff that's going on in
this series they might also bring back
some Kamino wins from the prequels as
part of this plot we only know a little
bit about what happened to their people
in the planet Kamino after the prequels
it was recorded officially that the
Emperor shut down the cloning facility
on Kamino after revenge of the sith but
clearly we know that that's a lie and
that wasn't the end of his cloning
experiments from the events of rise of
Skywalker number two this is actually a
pretty big one the Lucasfilm people
revealed that we'd see more classic
characters from the original trilogy
Skywalker saga during season two I'm
trying to temper my expectations for
what that will look like people here
that they're doing classic
characters from the movies in
immediately they start thinking about
Luke Skywalker in the really big
characters but the only version of Luke
Skywalker that's actually been rumored
to appear on any of the Disney Plus
shows is a very very young little kid
version of Luke during the events of the
obi-wan Kenobi's series on Tatooine and
he'd only be around 10 or 11 years old
at best well that's happening even
though sebastian stan is probably
waiting by his phone on the set of
Falcon and Winter Soldier waiting for
that call to play adult Luke Skywalker
no joke he actually looks like Mark
Hamill's son in real life he really does
look like a young version of Luke so if
they ever did do adult Luke that was not
Mark Hamill he would be perfect for that
so when they say original trilogy
characters will be appearing during
season two I'm mostly just expecting
Bounty Hunter characters because even
though the show is really about what's
going on with baby Yoda there's supposed
to be a lot of bounty hunting happening
during the series so it just makes sense
if he's a bounty hunter he would run
into other classic bounty hunters who
are still alive in number one WTF
prediction this is also a pretty easy
one to we'll see new rogue Jedi and
force sensitive characters on the show
they're looking for the Jedi that
survived the purge that's one of the
armourers edicts to him go find other
Jedi to train him enemies sorcerers is
what they called them on the TV show
which I thought was hilarious there's
that special religious organization
centered around the forced faith the
Church of the force that appears during
the course of the new trilogy in Jedi
trainees who failed to complete their
training before the purge happened there
was even a storyline during season six
of the Clone Wars where there was a
holocron that the Jedi had with the
names of a bunch of force-sensitive
children all over the galaxy that had
yet to be contacted by the Jedi and
brought into the Jedi Temple for formal
Jedi training that could still be alive
in present day so I know that they're
gonna introduce any kind of holocrons or
anything like that but there's still a
lot of force sensitive children from the
original trilogy in prequel era that
because of the purge never went through
Jedi training but would still be alive
in present day and still be force
sensitive but I'm not expecting you at
all to show up suddenly or Yoda's force
ghosts or anything like that I think
most of the force sensitive characters
that they introduced on this show will
be completely brand new characters that
we've never seen before because if you
think about it the show has already
proven that it doesn't need major movie
characters to appear in order for
showed to be popular it's already crazy
huge with just baby Yoda and the
mandalorian who are two brand new
characters that we never saw before this
series what that allows them to do is
use the TV show to world build and
because there's not gonna be any more
Star Wars movies for a while the Disney
Plus series will be responsible for
expanding the Star Wars universe in
order to do that you have to introduce
new characters everyone let me know in
the comments though which new rogue Jedi
or deep cut for sensitive characters
from the expanded universe do you want
them to introduce on the show or bring
back into the Canon but I will keep
doing Mandalorian videos throughout the
year we're probably gonna get a trailer
sometime by the summer because they're
almost done filming season two right now
they're well into doing their season two
episodes so it shouldn't be that long
before we get some more teasers
congratulations
seal phantom you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Star Wars video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details
everyone click here for my Mandalorian
season 2 teaser and episode 8 ending
scene and click here for all my Witcher
Netflix episode videos with Henry Cavill
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome happy new year
you